So today I'm going to tell you the best three stories that I know.
I think these stories are absolutely phenomenally potent and the reason for that
is that I think they illustrate in an extraordinarily powerful way the nature of
the processes that led to the establishment of Western democratic ideals.
Rosia Aly outta whose work I rely on substantial substantially to make the
following argument has taken Western academic culture to task in a manner that
hasn't fully been revealed yet.
He said that like all human cultures,
the West is parochial and narrow in its viewpoint and although over the last 300
years there's been a substantial amount of cross cultural intermingling and a
potential broadening of philosophical and religious horizon.
That broadening has not been sufficiently complete.
If we build on the viewpoint that I've been developing with you over the last
few courses and make the presupposition that religious modes of thinking are
more phenomenological than they are rational,
which means that they deal more with what you experience say.
Then with the objective world.
If we look at our Keck religious stories through that Lens,
then they can start to open up and so given that I want to open up three
religious stories to you today too in depth and one only in passing because
we'll return to it later.
I'll start with a Judaeo Christian myth of genesis.
When I say myth,
I don't mean untrue,
I mean a form of knowledge that's narrative instructor and predicated on
presumptions that aren't empirical.
A myth describes processes of transformation.
A myth describes the process whereby elements of experience come into being and
transform.
The fundamental structural
elements of genesis are the word of God and chaos
and Hebrew words for chaos and waste.
Our town for chaos and tow who for waste and Tom in particular,
although tto who as well are very interesting words because you can track their
derivation historically and sometimes if you can track the derivation of words
historically you can get some sense of the culture mill you out of which the
word spraying.
And we know what time at means because we have written records of a story that
involves a character named ty Matt.
And timeout is a dragon who lives at the bottom of the ocean.
In the oldest myth we have,
which is the Enuma Elish,
the Samarian creation myth,
Sumeria,
Babylon Acadia,
rightly regarded as the birthplace of modern western civilization
in genesis two,
processes unite to produce being
the first of those processes are states,
is chaos represented by Taya Marto,
who the second of those processes is logos.
And Logos is another word that has an extraordinarily broad range of meaning.
It's generally
transcribed in the Christian tradition has the word,
and it's identified with Christ,
which is a very peculiar identification because it's the word of God that
creates order out of chaos.
And of course,
the word of God in Genesis is a phenomena that predates the birth of Christ
infinitely from a classical religious perspective.
So the fact that the two beings are identified as of great peculiarity and also
of great interest.